[Musique]
n'avoir rien à manger c'est la réalité
pour plusieurs personnes présentement
temps on voit que la pandémie alors
précipité des situations précarité et de
vulnérabilité
ce qui était déjà en insécurité
alimentaire des kits qui vivaient déjà
dans la précarité pour rester encore
plus plus grave donc ce qu'on voit c'est
évidemment des inégalités qui ce qui
augmente à tous les niveaux pour ces
personnes
dans le quartier saint en vie par
exemple ces inégalités sont grandes mais
gare à ces amours-là japon
mais la communauté ici quand d'aider les
plus démunis avec le projet nourrir en
vie le frigo qui est là c'est un frigo
que les propriétaires de la friperie
nous ont permis de placer là il est visé
est accessible en tout temps qu'elle se
trient couleurs ressortent de la rose
tous les jours par des gens de la
communauté
c'est hallucinant j'ai plein de bons
retours
un frigo est installée dehors juste à
côté il y a un petit gars manger où
chacun peut prendre ce qui lui plaît
quand ça lui plaît c'est un vrai esprit
de communauté
c'est le quartier qui se met ensemble le
nom du projet s'appelle nourrir henry et
donc c'est vraiment une initiative de
gens du coin qui sont dit il faut qu'on
y procède et en plus cela on voit
qu'avec la pandémie là les besoins sont
en hausse c'est terrifiant environ 22%
de la population québécoise soit près de
deux millions de personnes ont déclaré
avoir vécu de l'insécurité alimentaire
depuis la pandémie
la chercheuse geneviève mercil on a
mesuré la gravité
l'insécurité alimentaire grâce et invite
pour ça la population qui aurait vécu
une situation grave
c'est très préoccupant on peut se priver
de repas pendant des journées entières
il ya vraiment la fin qui s'installe
qu'il est pour ça c'est beaucoup parce
qu'habituellement c'est trois fois moins
que ce soit ces dix jours ap ça c'est la
classe madras et la restauration kfc
si on a des piments le personnes
cagettes doit retirer de la table
isabelle au but et épicière 80 % de sa
clientèle c'est la restauration le
commerce
elle se retrouvait donc avec des surplus
d'aliments et vendus et ne trouvait
aucun organisme pour venir les récupérer
la maison du partage ne vient plus enfin
un autre
une oeuvre caritative d'avant ne vient
plus on a des produits on jette pour
1000 $ par semaine de frise et légumes
j'ai dit ok je m'en occupe
quel est restauratrice
mais en raison de la pandémie elle a été
contrainte de fermer définitivement les
portes de son restaurant
elle s'implique dans le projet du frigo
et vient aujourd'hui récupérer les
aliments est vendu chez au but bon on va
laisser beaucoup des fruits ou
indirectement le frigo et après les
autres produits ce qu'elle jouait du
chou-fleur il ya de la mangue aussi il
ya des patates sont des poivrons tadla
lixus garder un peu plus longtemps on va
l'envoyer chez des les cuisinières qui
vont transformer faire des plats prêts à
manger pour le dépanner pour de nos
familles à la fin de la semaine qui leur
est qu'il faut manger tout de suite on
va les déposer dans le frigo
qu'est ce qu'ils font les organismes
mais ils sont allés vers les mesures
d'urgence
mais les organismes ne font pas que de
la mesure d'urgence
ils font plein d'autres services
beaucoup de ces services là ont dû être
délesté assez comme notre réseau
hospitalier là tout ce filet social
qu'on a avec notre réseau communautaire
au québec quand même qui n'est pas rien
c'est plusieurs milliers mais ce ce
réseau là et est mise à mal
on se rend compte que finalement
l'épicier le restaurateur puis après ça
les autres restaurateurs aussi en barque
[Musique]
selon sébastien rioux les banques
alimentaires font un travail exemplaire
mais la problématique est plus grande
on n'est jamais en train d'attaquer le
problème plus fondamental de qui est la
pauvreté qui est l'insécurité financière
est ce que l'on voit présentement à mon
avis c'est justement une démonstration
assez évidente de l'augmentation de la
pauvreté très importante au québec et
ailleurs et de l'inefficacité des
mesures en place d'un point de vue
sociétal ou même au niveau du
gouvernement ou est ce que j'ai vu
beaucoup surtout la quantité de gens qui
ont du travail et qui sont obligés
d'avoir recours à de l'aide de
nourriture
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de femmes
monoparentales encore une fois moi c'est
ce qui me frappe le plus petit qui
m'interrogent n'est plus aussi alors
j'espère qu'on aura une bonne surprise
aujourd'hui où il ya du stock
la soupe à la dame fait baiser un pâté
chinois un par personne s'il vous plaît
parce qu'il faut partager puis à chinese
but macaronis qui veut délicieux qui
avait plus que maintenant ce sont des
petits gestes comme ça individuel ou en
tout cas qui sont à l'échelle
communautaire qui viennent pallier aux
insuffisances du système d'un
d'alimentaire au moins c'était moins
justement de l'augmentation assez
dramatique de l'insécurité alimentaire
surtout dans un contexte d'augmentation
du prix des aliments mais également dans
la 2
d'augmentation du prix du logement est
vraiment devenu complètement dingue on
aide de 33 familles qui reçoivent des
paniers dont plusieurs avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'enfants on est un des seuls
pays et où est-ce qu'on n'a pas de
mesures d'alimentation universel dans
les écoles sont aussi que ça pourrait
donner un sérieux coup de main pour les
ménages avec des femmes et par exemple à
mon avis en fait la question de
l'alimentation et de la sécurité
alimentaire devrait un droit de vote est
un droit social
les personnes dans un état comme le
québec qui devrait avoir fait un petit
calcul pas fondées cour des grands avec
un fromage mais j'étais bien là déjà
contribué qu'il s'agissait d autres il
j'ai fait une sélection de fruits et
légumes n'est ce pas en faire mon
restaurant
je me suis rendu compte que j'avais un
besoin moi aussi de dd de le continuer
de nourrir les gens d'une autre manière
ça aide aussi à relativiser quand on
prend un petit via les petits tchèque
on va bien et que ça fait du bien aussi
d